uh
oh now we have it okay good
good good good
then i won't keep vlad waiting anymore
and i'll just
start making moves sorry but for all the
nonsense
hopefully there there isn't that
there aren't that many hiccups coming up
d3 it's a bit surprising
let's go for something
a little bit forcing bishop b4
slides are generally
okay for black
this a bluff
i don't know takes takes
takes queen e2
rookie one probably isn't that great for
me
it's castle instead rookie one
rookie eight there's maybe it takes c
takes and then bishop g5 and that could
be
less than ideals let's just take an e4
it's gonna be pretty symmetrical but
usually there's a lot of play even in
this position so now i want
this
yes i do like stephen curry he's pretty
it's on a pretty insane streak right now
it's a random question though
let's go bishop c7 get that bishop out
of
out of the file maybe rook d8
maybe develop the other the other bishop
how did i even manage to
find a question yeah i know
so i think i think
the conclusion after all is that
people they don't like
mods when they have them
and then when they don't have mods
they want mods because it's
um because it becomes just
too spammy and too ridiculous is that it
i think that must be it
i'm moving this rook here since i don't
know where where to put
this bishop here i don't want to put it
here because he will just
chase it away with h3 and if i go bishop
e6 he
may have knight g5
and the rook may be decently placed a
knife
eight if i go for a a5 a4
at some points
it's really spending oceans of time
though
i'm not sure it's the best strategy okay
now i'll go in five
i'm not sure you played this very sorry
accurately
um i guess this is reasonable what is
done here but he has
he has given me the square on d4
so the question is should i just jump in
or can i wait for
a better moment
i'm not sure i can't wait well i can't
wait of course but
i'm not sure i've been useful most
knight f4
bishop f4 e4 looks very unconvincing
bishop b6 should be three maybe
don't feel like i have a lot there
um yeah okay let's go bishop b6
now you're fine there is
yeah so bishop e3 and i go for 94.
think of tank pull the tank again
rook a2 looks artificial and rook d1
i'll take an a3
so he has to take rook d4
i think i'm a little bit better but
realistically it's
pretty hard to win i believe
yeah let's try it off
his strong bishop i'm hoping
this pawn is a little bit weak knight f5
is interesting it's not what i would
have
would have done
i feel like yeah maybe his bishop is
strong but
my knight is also very it's also very
good
okay let's centralize
not into crypto
queen b2 maybe
here would be three yeah never mind
let's just take
oh there's squinny too
also queen c4 now i got 95 though
[Music]
don't have that much time you can go a5
a4a5 here is good compensation
this wasn't ideal
i should mention that if i had gone if
i'd gone rook f8
instead i would get me i got mated in
beautiful style so
make sure i have time to show the line
but
trust me okay
queen g5 maybe
it doesn't rook d8 yeah maybe i need to
start
bailing out here this is most probably a
draw even though
[Music]
i'm still i can still
claim at least a symbolic advantage
it takes but then i don't think he's
completely equalized here
he should make a draw
p5
okay let's go king g6 first then bring
the knight
do i have problems actually defending
that pawn
i don't have time do i
okay let's go
i don't think i should have done this
now i can play for one without risk at
the very least
i'll get h h3
h5 h4 i think that's favorable for me
maybe he's defending this well
yeah he's defending well i'm not sure i
can win this
i had to go back with the king
yeah bishop g8 is the threat
unfortunately
don't have any winning chances anymore
okay i'm just going to force the draw
so i had nothing there
another draw